i thought we'd have a little look at a
neat little algorithm that actually is
super super popular and that's iterative
closest point so the icp algorithm is
used all the time to align point clouds
either in two dimensions three
dimensions or maybe even more right
depending on what you're doing so for
example
if you're using a robot and you're
examining a scene and you've got lidar
you're going to be finding lots and lots
of data points saying this is a surface
over here and it's this far away and the
question is if you're driving along and
you're capturing this lidar repeatedly
you've got to try and put all these
point clouds together into a bigger one
that represents your whole the whole
space that you're in and the question is
how do we actually align lots of sets of
points like this
so i've done a slightly smaller scale
version here right you've got to imagine
this is millions and millions of points
repeatedly at i don't know
multiple times a second from some
expensive laser scanner now i have don't
have an expensive laser scanner nor is
this 3d but if the exact same principles
apply iterative closest point is also
used for things like image stitching and
can be used for lots of different things
so you know it's very very common
essentially this is the problem right so
what we've done we've i mean i've drawn
some points on here right these are in
two dimensions and i'm just going to
copy these points over here to pretend
that what i've done is captured a second
sample of these points at some later
time but between those two times maybe
i've moved or the camera's moved or the
object has moved and so maybe my points
are sitting over here or something like
this right now i'm using this kind of
baking paper
as my best effort of obtaining some sort
of tracing paper is this your um
audition for number five
yeah yeah i mean we'll see how it goes
right it's it's partially partially
seafood that was what i went with um i
considered making my own tracing paper
but it looked really messy this is our
sort of reference cloud so this is some
amount of points that we scanned ahead
of time let's say in the previous lidar
scan or earlier when we did a laser scan
of an object right it's quite common for
example in films you know you might
build a masking or an object you want to
to animate in three dimensions using
like clay using an artist or something
like this and then maybe you laser scan
this to get a nice mesh it's the idea so
anyway you've got some points and we've
now captured some other points
over sitting over here right now
these look like the same points but and
to me it's pretty obvious you just go
like this right but humans are quite
good good at this problem um we're good
at pattern recognition the question is
if you're a computer how do you do this
how do you work out what the correct
rotation and the correct translation is
so that you can intersect these points
as close as possible some points might
be missing there might be too many
points
things like this and the other issue
you've got is you have to do it really
really quickly right because if you do a
brute force search of all the possible
rotations and all the possible
translations you will eventually stumble
upon this but it could take you hundreds
of thousands of years so that that isn't
going to help you when you're trying to
reconstruct your lidar scan you know in
real time as you drive through a scene
or something like this
so what we're going to do well let's
what's the problem we're trying to solve
for each of these points we want to find
the point that sits on this cloud
which we don't know
and then we want to minimize the
distance from that point so for example
if we had a pair between this point and
this point then quite simply we want to
minimize the euclidean distance between
these two so pythagoras essentially so
he's going to do that right and for one
point that's not so difficult right even
for two points you can kind of just sort
of you can just sort of do that
the problem is that in this situation we
don't have this correspondence we don't
know that this point goes with this
point and this point goes with this
point right i only know them because i
just drew them out and there's not very
many points right for millions of points
i'm going to struggle too so
the question is what do we do iterative
closest point the word iterative means
you know we iterate this number of times
the idea is that we first try and find
the best possible combination of matches
or correspondences between these points
and then given those correspondences we
try and optimize the translation and
rotation and that will be okay and then
we will repeat that process and we'll
try it again
that's the idea so let's have a go i
just literally drew these at random so i
have no idea if this is a good example
or not but we'll try it
let's imagine this is where my points
are now of course if i move this around
this is all going to go wrong so the
closest point to this one
is is this and the closest point to this
is probably also this and maybe this in
fact quite a lot of them connect to this
point which is not ideal let's just for
the sake of being a little bit more
interesting say that these two connect
over here right so something like that
what we do now is that we ignore all
these points because these points
essentially what we're saying in this
situation is that they're not anything
to do with this mesh maybe this has got
a million points and we've only taken a
small extra scan we're just adding in
some more points so
what we can now do is calculate the
center of mass of these two points which
is here and the center of mass of these
points which is here and we can put them
in the same place right and then we can
rotate this so that the distances of
each of these points to the originals
is minimized so these ones remember go
to this one so we can try and sort of
rotate it so that it's sort of there
right something like this and that's our
first iteration now it's clear to me
having done this that my drawing lines
on doesn't make any sense because now i
can't move the lines we're going to have
to pretend the lines are gone
wipe them off will it wipe off that
paper
no it's a sharpie no no no it's fine
it's fine um
yeah we we
people can see what i'm doing right so
let's and then what we're going to do is
we're going to iterate this process so
we're going to do the correspondence
problem again so actually this one now
goes to here this one goes to here
let's say there there there and there
and then what we do
is we repeat this process so we can say
okay so given the center of mass of
these points that we've matched to and
our new points we can kind of move it
over here and then maybe we adjust the
rotation a little bit as well and then
we reassign some points and we move it
over here and we adjust the rotation and
we reassign and we repeat this process
for some number of iterations but slowly
moves these points towards one another
right that's the idea so it's actually a
super straightforward algorithm
and eventually what hopefully happens is
you kind of get the right
correspondences and once you've got the
right correspondences
your translation and your rotation
should solve it to put these exactly
where they're supposed to be there's a
few caveats here right i've gone from
here all the way over to here that is
not guaranteed with iterative closest
point because if your correspondences
are completely bogus then your movement
is going to be super bogus and you're
just not going to find anything good you
know maybe we end up settling on what we
call a local minimum
where visa getting corresponded with
these points here and you just never get
anything better than this and it just
sits there and finishes the other for
example if this was upside down and
they're back to front it might kind of
do this
and it's kind of pretty close but it's
not going to be able to completely flip
it around necessarily and solve that
problem right so
there's a lot more to iterative closest
point if you read the literature on it
because there's lots of other strategies
you could use so for example imagine
that this is only a very small point
cloud because again we've captured some
extra scan and it represents some small
part of some object and this is a huge
point cloud that we've been
reconstructing over many iterations what
we might want to do is ignore most of
these points that are too far away you
know so if we start over here and
there's a bunch of stuff here maybe we
want to ignore it because it's too far
away from where we're aiming for and try
and pull it in the right direction
there are other ways you can calculate
correspondences but basically all of
these approaches are aiming to shorten
the number of steps it took
to solve this problem i mean if i go
back i could actually use my lines how
clever um right so this was where i
wasn't originally right
um and it was what it was about one two
it's about one you know two three it was
about four or five iterations
bearing in mind that there's nothing
accurate about what i just did but
about four or five iterations got us
from over here to here which is pretty
nice that's going to be much much
quicker than trying to do some kind of
massive brute force search of all pairs
of points from here to here which is
going to be you know n squared it's
going to be huge um and this is not a
normal a number of points returned by a
lidar scanner 100 you know thousands
multiple times a second you know at 60
hertz or something like this right we're
talking a lot of points
so
most of the research on this is about
trying to
first of all find iterative closest
point approaches that solve even when
your initial estimate is rubbish right
and also converge very quickly
so in this case i came up with an
initial estimate of here you know if i
just got given this over here i can't
this is this is less likely to work so i
needed to find something that was
sufficiently close so you need kind of
almost like a head start because if that
was up here near all those points we've
ignored then you've got no chance yeah
that's right and and actually what
happens in practice you might imagine is
you you manually start this process so
you say i mean not for automatic lidar
but suppose you're stitching meshes for
3d reconstruction you might say well
i've got these i think it's about there
and that that will converge extremely
quickly you know and one way you can do
this is where we have actual
corresponding points so we could say
this is point a and this is also point a
and this is point b and this is point b
and just for a few points you can
immediately get some kind of initial
transformation which can then be you
know adjusted right assuming maybe i
clicked on slightly the wrong point or
something like that how do you work out
what the best kind of translation and
rotation is well without correspondences
between these points that's very very
difficult which is i guess the whole
point of the algorithm once you know
that let's say this point goes with this
one and this one goes with this one and
so on then actually
it's it's pretty simple matrix matrix
maths so first of all you can just
calculate the difference between the
centers and translate them like that
that's that's fairly straightforward and
then you can do what we call singular
value decomposition which is basically a
way of working out in one step what the
optimal rotation would be but will
minimize these distances so this isn't
this is you know a known mathematical
process it takes a little bit of time
the more the more points you have so if
you have millions of points against
millions of points you wouldn't do that
you would sub-sample some of the points
and do smaller amounts of overlap in
fact we can demo this now and i can show
you this process all right so we'll get
the laptop out and we'll have a look now
i've downloaded something called the
stanford bunny are you familiar with
this the stamford bunny no you've
probably never heard it's probably the
most famous 3d model you know you might
not have heard of but it's it's it's a
it's a bunny rabbit a ceramic bunny
rabbit that was scanned i think in the
90s or early 2000s i can't remember i
should know exactly when it scan very
very commonly used in computer vision
to
um fantastic to test reconstruction
stitching you know up shading
anything graphical you can use a
stanford bunny as a kind of
baseline mesh model there's a number of
these from this repository the bunny's
perhaps the most common all right so
i've installed mesh lab now you have to
forgive me because it's been some years
since i've used mesh lab it's coming
back to me slowly but i mean there's
buttons in different places i think
since last time so i've downloaded the
bunny and i've cleaned it up a bit
because
this actually this bunny was actually
computed by a laser scanner and the
thing that laser scanners produce just
like in our last video is a depth map
it's a very accurate depth map but you
can't see behind things so what you've
got is a lot of halves and bits of bunny
that just don't fit over each other at
all so for example if i load all these
in
you can see that what we've got is just
an absolute mess of of bunny
all facing in different directions and
it's not quite clear what we do
so the first thing to do perhaps is hide
some of these meshes so we can see a
little bit better i'm going to zoom in
i've got this mouse which should if i
press this button
magically connect to this laptop much
easier to use with a mouse so i'll hide
some of these and let's just look at two
of these meshes okay so we've got two
messages which we've got two meshes
which is a hard word to say lots of
times quickly
and they kind of align
you can see there's this beside a bunny
rabbit head here side of bunny rabbit
head
and what we're going to do is we're
going to stitch these using iterative
closest points so i'm going to press the
align button i'm making you know to be
fair not that much effort right someone
actually already stitched the bunny
which is the model everyone actually
uses i'm only looking at these two you
can see them in different colors and
what the first thing i'm going to do is
do that key point localization just to
say it's roughly here right and it won't
be brilliant but it'll be okay so i'm
going to go in i'm going to i'm going to
i'm going to pick this first bunny as
our reference that's the one that's
going to be static and then the other
one is going to move towards it at least
that's the hope so i'm going to glue
that mesh here and a little star means
that it's fixed now the next one i'm
going to select this one and i'm going
to say point-based gluing and now i've
got a new window up which shows both
meshes and i can kind of click on so i
can double click on this eye here and
that eye here and maybe the top of the
ear and the top of that ear and that's
roughly the same place i mean i don't
need to be super accurate it's not quite
clear how i do the front of his face i'm
going to sort of click there
that's about right and then maybe a bit
of tail
i mean i'm literally making this up as i
go along you need about four points and
then you can quite easily calculate the
rotation and translation matrix that
will get you a little bit of a way
towards this uh so let's go right that
is not actually that bad you can see but
it's not if i zoom in you can see it's
not really aligned right there's a few
bits missing and the ears are a little
bit off actually i'm quite pleased with
that this is a bit off anyway what we
can now do is we can use iterative
closest point
to very quickly just go and just just
just tidy that last bit up which is of
course what you want to do if you were
putting this into any kind of um
serious graphics or anything like this
so all i need to do is press process now
this automatically runs until some
minimum error is reached i'm going to
change it to maximum iterations of one
just so we can see it happening rather
than just going ta-da so it's like step
through it sort of thing that's right so
i'm going to click process and it's just
going to run one iteration where it
corresponds points to the nearest points
moves them a little bit and then stops
right and what we'll do is click that
and it did something right you might
have to zoom in zoom in to see what it
did you can see there's a little gap
here i'm going to click process a few
times and it's sort of moving in the
right direction and you can see it
doesn't go back quickly because it's
correspondence problem there's a lot of
points here it's a bit noisy but it's
actually working pretty well and i'd say
that they're pretty well aligned now
um at least good enough for this
demonstration let's have a look at
another one of these models so if i if
this has now been fixed if i unhide this
one this is the other side of the bunny
i'm not sure i've got enough
corresponding points between these two
so i might try what about
that one yeah that's got some some some
bunny head on it it's all very
scientific and exact what i'm doing here
so again we'll just go back to uh click
on this do some point blaze gluing so um
i don't know i mean something up
something about
i'm i'm not sure these are aligned
because um there may not be enough
points in common but i think probably
so
yeah okay actually well
there we go so there's about four points
oh it's not disastrous is it actually
that's pretty good um it's not quite
aligned you can see there's a bit of a
gap uh there so what's the button to me
oh there we go so there's there's quite
a big gap actually is this close enough
we will see i'm gonna click process a
bit
oh actually it worked pretty well
oh nice
quite pleased with that we don't need to
use the stanford bunny anymore we can
use mike's special reconstructive stand
for bunny which will be superior
right you can see this actually there's
some artifacts here from the laser
scanning which would need to be removed
because what you want to do is of each
of the views of your bunny you want to
select only divide best bits of the mesh
where it was looking straight on
and then discard all the edgy bits that
are not so good and then overall you get
a really really you know solid model all
right so that's that's pretty much it to
close this point you could actually i
mean in national you can do all these at
the same time and just optimize the
whole thing
you know but
it's it's a very effective algorithm and
it's very very quick right if i hadn't
have had to click process every time
because i did that myself
this would have happened in a fraction
of a second i know there's something
like 50 or 60 000 points on each of
these bits of bunny right so that's not
a trivial
you know comparison to make
unless you're doing some smart stuff
about it so it's a really cool algorithm
is mesh lab one of these amazing really
expensive tools no it's totally free i
think it's open source and definitely
have a play around so you can download
the stand for bunny we'll put a link in
the description and download mesh lab or
cloud compare is another really good one
there's various others and just click
the align button and start playing
around with bits of bunny and it's good
good fun for everyone